hello everyone and welcome back to some
more rapid action unleashes uh last game
we were able to get a win with the white
pieces in none other than the Evans
Gambit so we'll uh try to try to play
actively in the next one as well see
what happens so let's create a game and
yeah everything's uh the same as before
we are playing high rated players uh
trying to explain our thought process
and uh hoping to get a good positions
and not blunder too much in some of the
games I do blunder but uh yeah I don't
know uh sometimes uh uh I don't know
maybe my tactical awareness just isn't
what it was 10 or 15 years ago uh so um
you know what what are you going to do
uh still managing to win some games
we'll see if I'll be able to continue
that but I'm guessing uh okay even if I
get to maybe like 23 2350 it will be
very very hard to continue from that
point on if I if I continue blundering
pieces uh so let's uh let's start with
E4 that's been working working well for
us for for now and our opponent goes for
D6 and G6 so some sort of a a pce modern
setup uh and we're just going to tackle
it with F4 uh since we don't know much
Theory here let's uh grab as much space
as possible let's even play E5
here yeah our opponent says that uh it's
possible to play like
this uh if it is okay we're going to
play Bishop
C4 sorry about that I just have to F the
sound a little bit he'll probably go
something like C6 and then we're even
getting some sort of
uh alin's defense type structure maybe
where he went Knight F6 I play E5 he put
Knight here and then maybe something
like let's say Knight B6 Bishop B3 C3 uh
and he just castles in yeah it does
appear to be some sort of
a some sort of
Ain maybe with a different move order
not sure if uh
not sure if it's the exact same thing
but uh yeah usually when I have this
against the Alin I I I want to put my
knight on e4 that's like the dream uh
and he goes for the immediate uh Bishop
H4 I will play H3 if he wants to trade
not really sure about trading the
Bishops here yeah okay he does trade
will be will be a lot of fun and our
opponent is uh
Michael Michaelangelo
Michel
angelu uh no idea from where so okay he
plays E6 very standard strengthens D5
but weakens F6 and uh we really want to
get our Knight to to D4 Square we just
have to make sure we don't blunder
anything while doing
so and uh it's a pretty solid setup but
uh yeah I've never I've never liked this
for black uh problem is it's just uh
much easier to find moves for white like
already here you you can see some dark
squares dark Square uh issues yeah he
has to play F6 and I'm kind of already
not buying
this yeah okay so what is what is
F6 what is
F6
okay and if he takes with the bishop the
king will just be completely crippled
and if he takes with the Knight we're
just going to go after the E6
Pawn Yeah does seem to make
sense yeah he will try to create some
sort of a defense here but I don't think
uh yeah okay if I go Knight G5 he might
have Knight
D5 uh but
nah I'm I'm seriously not buying
this that you can weaken the uh your
position like this yeah okay so he will
go for that I can even play Bishop
captures on D5 whereas you know if he
captures uh my queen I can play Bishop
captur here and win his queen as
well so it's uh definitely interesting
but there's no real reason to do it I
can just pile up on the on the E6 Pawn
here
yeah on the other hand it is uh it is a
clean
Pawn Yeah I don't know do they keep the
tension with Queen G4 then he trades I
trade he BL plays Rook back to fade I
play King G1 do I have time to bring my
bishop and The Rook into the game all
while attacking the6 Pawn or do I just
uh do I just play Bishop captures on D5
that's
that's kind of the question
here but okay on Bishop captures he can
also play Queen captur so we'll just
play
this yeah he will
trade luckily he doesn't have this Fork
after the trade since our Bishop covers
the E3
Square yeah he'll he'll play Rook f8
check I'll play King G1 and then I
develop my dark square bishoping at The
Rook inter game and he will have to
somehow figure out how to deal with this
uh E6
Pawn Yeah I I don't know it looks it
looks really bad for black uh you know I
would hate to think
that Black's only problem here will be
the weak
Pawn okay so he goes he goes uh to
defend and
now what do we go for now
yeah okay we'll just develop the
bishop nothing spectacular happening
here he might play Knight A5 it would
it's definitely a good idea to kick this
bishop away from this diagonal and then
if you can if you can maybe play E5
should be good for him but he will not
be able to do that as long as the queen
is very poorly placed on D7 so those are
some of the issues that he has to figure
out
um
okay Knight
here
H yeah we'll go to F3
sure sure why
not but black still faces all of the all
of the same uh
issues and he his King side isn't
improving all that
much
yeah okay my position also has some
issues of the King on F1 is obviously
very
weird uh so I will have to move it back
to G1 at some
point and I have to decide whether I
want my Rook on E1 or F1 and whether is
G6 evening a Target here am I interested
in that yeah he will defend it and now
he basically forces my
hand yeah I'm going to move the king
king F1 and he might have Queen F5 here
here Queen F5 might be might not be a
terrible might not be a terrible move
but still E6 Pawn will be weak yeah we
don't care about
that yeah and if Queen F5 it doesn't
really come up with uh all the many
threats I can even play Queen G3 with
some threats of winning some material
here well I'm not really interested in
that I'm mostly interested in just
getting my Rook into the
game okay Queen
F5 uh trading is nothing any in between
moves not really going my way uh so
we'll just go for
this now we are threatening some captur
and queen captures on C7 it's not not
about winning a pawn it's about going
after uh the the weak parts of his
structure and then pretty much
everything will collapse okay so he just
gives it up not not right away of course
he first
first attacks my Bishop so do we have a
nice in between
move are we considering Knight
H4 we are considering it of course we're
considering
everything yeah let's go Knight
H4 does look does look very nice puts
pressure on G6 also gives me control
over D3 uh so he he might play Queen C2
yeah that could be
annoying
yeah Queen C2 might be annoying a little
bit
H yeah this is becoming very
interesting yeah no he doesn't want to
go after it
he's he's afraid of all of my activity
here yeah now okay Bishop is nice
here putting pressure on the pawn here
if please G5 I can even put a knight
there no I can even yeah I can put a
knight there
H yeah let's go here and maybe E5
becomes nah okay first he has to deal
with uh with all of this if I play
Bishop to B3 I might have allowed
something like
this yeah it just looks really bad for
black
because now yeah now now this I can even
play Bishop G6 and it's game over I can
even trade here and my position is
overwhelmingly overwhelmingly
overwhelming
yeah can I can I do even better than
that no I don't think I can I think this
is more than
enough it's more than
enough
yeah it looked like at some point it
looked like there was some issue with my
position but
uh uh yeah okay we can I mean it's not
really necessary to trade here but
uh it's just yeah okay let's stop Knight
C4 maybe bit of unnecessary but do I
need to stop and I can just play Bishop
C1 and decide what I want to do
next yeah maybe it's
uh yeah he can play
it um the pawns are actually fine here I
don't want to
like unnecessarily push a pawn
yeah okay so he defends this Pawn which
is very nice and we're going
to we're going to
go yeah he's being very very tricky
here yeah I might as well have played
this I might as well have played
this
yeah not a lot for him to do here so
yeah okay the Knight here isn't very
useful
um we'll just improve our position here
attack the dh4 pawn he's going to put a
knight on F5 but that's going to pretty
much blockate his
position
I should get my king to F3 yeah I'm
trying to win this without uh
calculating too much okay he's going to
go for that
sure okay so he he actually found a way
to to do some damage here
interesting luckily he doesn't have this
because this comes with check yeah okay
I will take this with check he will
double his pawns but
uh that's all there is the Knight is a
tricky bastard I will give him that yeah
let's go
here let's go here just
uh okay let's go here just to take away
squares from the black
king let's take
here
yeah I feel like I really could have
played this a little bit
better uh but that's the that's the
problem when you have a a good position
you feel like everything is is
sufficient but yeah okay he will get
some activity with his King but still
shouldn't be shouldn't be a
problem yeah you can go
there
okay so let's uh let's push the C
Pawn not right away though not right
away let's go after
that okay so he stops my advancement but
now we go after
the the real weaknesses we do allow him
into the position a little
bit Yeah feels
uh
yeah I was looking for ways to give up
my Rook for the Knight and just you know
win at least one Pawn uh but he's
uh yeah let's okay let's go after this
Pawn all right so now it's completely
winning we don't have to worry about it
anymore H he has no checks he has no
tricks um my my Pawn is simply too fast
and next we attack the Knight and we
advance the pawn and that's it so yeah
pretty pretty nice
nice yeah if he goes after the king we
can even take because if King captures
we can win the Knight so this also
works uh but yeah really yeah he's not
interested in that so what's is this
better or is this better what's
better yeah if I take he doesn't have to
take my Pawn
so yeah I feel this is cleaner
feels a bit
cleaner yeah okay you can give a check
I'm not going to go anywhere where you
can check
me but you have to try when whenever you
have a knight you have to try maybe you
know I put my king on a weird Square
okay he resigns uh good game Michael
Michel
angelu uh now let's check out what we
did what we did wrong as I'm sure as I'm
sure we uh made quite a few mistakes
there I just didn't feel that he
played it
uh you know to the okay so you have to
play C4 here obviously yeah this is some
sort of
a some sort of a fine setup for white uh
I was going into what what what was
familiar for me which is some sort of a
setup that I use against the Alin
defense and again yeah Bishop to G4 not
the best and uh yeah I went Knight E4
see here I'm already objectively winning
he played F6
n yeah what no Knight C5 is best here
because if he moves Knight capture wow
Knight captures on E6 yeah yeah tactics
all around tactics all around uh but
yeah okay I played this it's still
winning but yeah still Knight C5 yeah I
missed that one I don't know why I
missed that one probably because when I
play against the alakin defense the
Knight always wants to go to G5 but okay
yeah Knight C5 was much cleaner here I
went Knight G5 he went Knight D5 I
played Queen G4 captures
captures
yeah okay so this is all uh perfectly
fine yeah fine fine fine fine
fine uh so I'm basically winning the
entire
game yeah now the end game probably
could have been uh decided a bit more
cleanly I was unnecessary to allow most
of the things that I did but yeah it was
uh wasn't really an issue at any point
yeah completely winning uh but
um yeah could have uh could have done it
much much
faster uh but I never yeah I kind of
feel ashamed to even admit this but I
was uh so happy that I was getting my
knight to E4 and G5 that I never
considered Knight to
C5 uh but okay when you when you will
have this position in a classical game
or you know in a in a serious rapid game
where you will be able to maybe uh take
your time and decide a bit more about
the position you will you will find such
moves I mean it's a a silly move to miss
the problem is Knight to G5 is also just
just strong so yeah it's always it's
difficult to find the moves when you
have like three good ones it's hard to
decide on the best one if it was the
only move to find I I you know I'm
confident that I would have found it but
yeah uh have to have to do better uh but
then I have to invest more time and then
I go into time trouble and then I lose
on time so you know how however I do it
never never really seems to work but we
we are winning for the moment so that
makes me happy and yeah we are getting
we are reaching that 2300 Mark and we'll
see how long we'll be able to uh to get
away with these kind of inaccuracies
probably at some point our opponents
will will start punishing us deeply uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it as usual you can check to all
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your
day